you see the smoke the water shooting out
the side of the building
people were running from the building it
was crazy
destruction at a southeast valley
grocery store the front awning at la
bonita supermarkets collapsed injuring
four and leaving a massive amount of
debris good afternoon and thank you so
much for joining us here at four i'm
christian casadas and i'm brian loftis
in for kirsten today now this all
happened a bit earlier this morning at
the location over on desert inn in
eastern madison kimbrell live there
right now with what we know about a
cause and where they go from here
madison the damage as we can see behind
you looks extensive
yeah it's really hard not to notice the
scene as you enter the parking lot i'm
going to step out of the way so you guys
can really see that's here on eastern
and desert inn look at the area of the
debris you can see wood bricks cement
all over insulation even metal piping
this awning collapse happened just after
six this morning clark county fire
rushed to the shopping center there were
initial reports of people trapped in the
rubble and we did get an update that
four people were transported to the
hospital with non-life-threatening
injuries i spoke to shoppers who can't
believe what they saw but they're glad
that no one was seriously hurt
it's been open for a long time and then
other than that for the upkeep of it
and then for something to happen like
this and structure wise
it's really terrible look all the lumber
and all that it looks old
i did get a statement from armando
martinez he's the general manager of la
bonita supermarkets he said quote our
desert in location will remain closed
until further notice all employees will
be given the day off fully paid and
offered any medical or emotional support
services if needed once they are ready
they will be relocated to another
location until we can reopen desert inn
stores now currently there are no
estimates on damage and the cause of the
collapse is still unknown 45 personnel
were taken and brought to this incident
right here early this morning so it was
an extensive scene and continues to be
throughout the night so we will be
bringing you the latest reporting live
madison kimbrough 8 news now